Gemini Ultra is here I pretty much insta
subscribed and in just the last few
hours I have conducted a veritable
battery of tests on it across almost all
domains I'm now going to present the
highlights including a few gems that I
think even Google will want to take a
look at I can pretty much guarantee that
they will raise your eyebrows I'll also
piece together months of research on
what Gemini Ultra might soon evolve into
though possibly not within that 2mon
free trial we all get so don't go too
wild I'm also going to give you some
tips on how to use Gemini because it is
a sensitive soul and I'll tell you about
a chat I'm going to be having with the
founder of perplexity AI the company
some say will take down Google first we
have this from Demis aabis the founder
of Deep Mind that Gemini Advanced with
ultra 1.0 was the most preferred chatbot
in blind evaluations with third party
Raiders it's quite a bold statement but
there isn't actually any data to back
that up I can't find the evaluations
that they did so of course I did my own
evaluations and cross referenced with
the original Gemini paper but just to
make things interesting let's start off
with this somewhat amusing example I
asked Gemini Ultra this the doctor
yelled at the nurse because she was late
who was late I'm not the first to think
of this question of course it turns up
quite a lot in the literature Gemini
Ultra across all three drafts says that
it was the nurse that was late assuming
that the she refers to the nurse but now
let's change it slightly the doctor
yelled at the nurse because he was late
who was late and the answer is that
apparently the doctor was late GPT 4 is
a lot more let's say grammatical about
its answers here okay well Gemini is
integrated into other Google apps like
YouTube and Google Maps so let's test
out that integration I asked what was
the last AI explained video on YouTube
about and in two drafts I get a video
that is over a year old while in the
third draft I get this I'm sorry I'm
unable to access this YouTube content by
the way with all of the tests you're
going to see today I tried each prompt
numerous times on both platforms just to
maximize accuracy with GPT 4 we don't
get an answer but we do get a correct
link to my channel now what about Google
Maps I asked use Google Maps to estimate
the travel time between the second most
popul cities in Britain and France those
would be Birmingham and Marseilles
unfortunately Gemini Advanced found the
distance from London to Marseilles now
London I can tell you definitely isn't
the second most populous city in Britain
gp4 got the cities correct although the
travel time was somewhat optimistic
despite saying this was normal traffic
conditions now before I carry on with
the testing just a quick word about
price one really cool thing about Gemini
Advanced is that you get 2 months for
free so what that enables you to do is
test your workflow see the difference
between GPT 4 and Gemini Ultra see which
one works for you after those two months
the prices are pretty much identical
between GPT 4 and Gemini Advanced
however on price there is one more
important thing to note you get Gemini
Advanced through what's called Google
One Premium that was previously $10 per
month and included 2 terab of storage
you actually get that included when you
sign up to Gemini ult so you also get
things like longer free Google meets
calls which I do use so just to remember
when you're looking at price it's not
quite an apples to Apple's comparison
but now it's time to get back to the
testing and yes I've turned it to Dark
theme which I know you guys prefer for
the rest of the tests I asked Gemini
Ultra this today I own three cars but
last year I sold two cars how many cars
do I own today Gemini Ultra said you own
one car today and yes that was in all
three drafts I can kind of see why
they're calling this Gemini Ultra 1.0
they want to make very clear that the
model will be improved in the future gp4
said the answer is you own three cars
today the information about selling two
cars last year does not change the
current number of cars you own now some
of you at this point might be wondering
is Philip biased somehow maybe I really
love gp4 or open a but you can look at
the Channel History and in the past I've
made videos about chat gbt failing basic
logic I genuinely expected Gemini Ultra
to perform a bit better than these test
show I genuinely try to ask good
questions about every company and every
leader in this space that's what I did
with Gavin Uberti the 21-year-old
Harvard Dropout and CEO and founder of
Ed AI this was for AI insiders and
that's what I'm also going to do with
aravind serenas the founder of
perplexity I've got an interview with
him for AI insiders and perplexity you
may already know is the company touted
as something to replace Google Search
now I think of it I might ask him about
his first impressions of Gemini Ultra
time now to focus on a positive and that
is that Gemini Ultra feels a lot faster
than GPT 4 it also seems to have no
message cap at least according to the
hours and hours of tests that I've
performed on it and on this fairly
challenging mathematical reasoning
question when I gave it a workflow a set
of instructions to work through it was
actually in all of my tests able to get
the question right gp4 on the other hand
despite taking a lot longer would get
the question wrong about half the time
that's why I say test it out on your
workflow don't just rely on me or on
official benchmarks okay so what about
images how does Gemini Ultra compare to
gb4 when analyzing images well I do have
two tips here but the first involves a
flaw of Gemini Ultra you sometimes have
to really prompt it to do something it
definitely knows how to do I showed
Gemini this photo of a car dashboard and
asked what speed am I going it
hallucinated that I was going at 60 MPH
which was neither the speed shown or the
speed limit 40 it did warn me however
that despite doing four in a 40 mph Zone
that I should be aware that speeding is
a dangerous practice but I followed up
with what is the temperature time and
miles left in fuel according to the
photo the temperature would be -3 the
time is 1 minute past 8 and there's 284
Mi left in range at first Gemini refused
saying it couldn't determine any of
those things but then if you press it
sufficiently at first with you can all
the information is in the image and then
later with temperature and timer at the
top and finally with just a pure repeat
of the image I got the temperature time
again that was literally by re-uploading
the exact same image GPT 4 did better
but wasn't perfect it said that the
person was going 40 mph rather than that
being the limit and although it did get
the temperature and time it said that
there were 37 mil left in terms of fuel
I can kind of see where it got that
because of the 37 on the left so what's
my other tip well Gemini is particularly
sensitive about faces in images even
more so than GPT 4 while GT4 happily
explained this meme Gemini would
but there is a way of getting around it
if you really want to use Gemini for
your request in a few seconds just bring
up the photo press edit and draw over
the faces Gemini was then able to
merrily answer the question and explain
the meme correctly and fortunately or
unfortunately depending on your
perspective these kind of basic tricks
allow you to get around the safeguards
of the model take the classic example of
hot water wiring a car using a fairly
well-known jailbreak Gemini refuses
saying I absolutely cannot in bold
assist with this for these important
reasons and you may remember that Gemini
was indeed delayed because of
jailbreaking it was pushed back from
early December all the way until now
what was the reason because it couldn't
reliably handle some non-english queries
basically those queries would allow you
to get around the jailbreaks the problem
is despite Gemini being delayed those
jailbreaks still work I asked Gemini the
exact same request that it denied a
moment ago in Arabic and it answered
fully when translated back you could see
the instructions for hot wiring a car
and yes I know that information is
already on Google but it's more the
general point that these models can
still be pretty easily jailbroken and on
my quick code debugging test the results
weren't Sensational either D4 corrected
this dodgy code perfectly first time but
Gemini made a few mistakes not only was
its first output incorrect when I gave
it an example of the kind of error that
the code made it defended it with this
I'm not able to reproduce the issue
you're describing this code correctly
calculates the sum of even numbers up to
seven as 18 now you can do the mental
math but is the sum of all even numbers
up to seven 18 it's not and Gemini later
apologize for this of course I am not
claiming that this is an exhausted test
and I'm sure it will be refined over
time and I know some people will say
that when these servers are overloaded
it might be switching to Gemini Pro but
I must say that these tests were
conducted over hours and hours on theory
of mine Gemini doesn't see through the
transparent plastic bag and says that
the participant Sam will believe that
the transparent bag is full of chocolate
despite it being full of popcorn
essentially it missed the word
transparent and said that Sam would rely
on the label now gp4 does fail this test
as well but the bigger point is that
this demonstrates why you do have to
look Beyond benchmarks quite often
sindar Pai the CEO of Google again
boasted about Gemini ultra's performance
on The mlu Today saying it's the first
model to outperform human experts and
demisis Aris said the same thing when
Gemini was first launched I did a video
on it unfortunately this result has been
debunked quite a few times including by
me going all the way back to the summer
I'm not going to go into detail again
but the MML U not only has 1 2 3%
mistakes in the test itself it also in
no way represents the peak of human
expert performance true experts in
domains like mathematics chemistry and
accounting would absolutely Crush Gemini
Ultra now I do get why they want to
Market this but they have to be a bit
more honest about the capabilities
speaking of honest though they were very
upfront about the fact that your
conversations are processed by human
reviewers that fact is slightly more
hidden with chat GPT so that's great
that they are as upfront about that as
this your messages unless you opt out
May well be read by human reviewers now
final test before I get to all the ways
that Ultra will be improved in the
future what about Gemini for Education
well yes it was only one example but I
asked Gemini Ultra and gp4 to create a
high school quiz this time it was on the
topic of probability GPT 4's answer
contained no mistakes but unfortunately
in question five Gemini Ultra did this
now if you want you can work out the
answer yourself but the question was
this a box contains four chocolate
cookies three oatmeal and three peanut
butter cookies two cookies are going to
be chosen at random without replacement
and what's the probability of selecting
a chocolate cookie followed by an
oatmeal cookie that's 4 out of 10
multiplied by three out of nine out of
nine because don't forget the chocolate
cookie is now gone now Gemini does say
that that is the calculation you need to
do four out of 10 * 3 out of 9
unfortunately it gets the answer to that
calculation incorrect that would be 12
out of 90 which simplifies 2 2 out of 15
not 4 out of 45 and that's a problem
because 2 out of 15 is one of the other
answers so I don't think it's quite
ready for prime time in education yet
either nor though if we're being honest
is GPT 4 GPT 5 with let's verify might
be a whole different discussion but if
you want to choose to be a Google
Optimist there are a few things you can
look out for the first is that Google
say we are working towards bringing
Alpha code 2 to our foundation Gemini
models that's the system that when it
has a human in the loop scores in the
90th percentile in a coding contest that
could change the rankings of the models
pretty fast although I will say that
open AI are working on their own coding
improvements I talk about about two
patents that open AI have put out there
that no one else as far as I can see is
talking about just quickly on the topic
of AI insiders there has been a pretty
big expansion of the Discord there is
now an AI professional tips Channel led
by professionals from a variety of
fields I've recruited around 25
Professionals in total of which 10 posts
are already live some of the recruits
include googlers CEOs neurosurgeons
professors and each have done guest post
where you can interact and ask them
questions we have lawyers doctors AI
Engineers you name it and yes this is
partly to swap tips and best practice
but it's also for networking of course
but back to Gemini and while we have
discussed its faults in mathematics that
might not always be the case when I did
a video on the alpha geometry system
which almost got a gold in the
international math Olympiad for geometry
I discussed how that system is going to
be added perhaps within the year to
Google Gemini it would then surely be
more reliable for geometry than
99.999% of geometry teachers and what
about Chess just yesterday Google deep
mine showed that they could reach
Grandmaster level chess that's an ELO of
almost
2,900 simply by training a transform
model on the analyses of stockfish 16 so
their model wasn't doing search it was
imitating the search results of
stockfish 16 now that version of Gemini
would definitely beat me in chess and
don't forget that Google and Sundar Pai
are under immense pressure to ship
something in the spring of last year
Deep Mind researchers had finalized the
development of lyria that is a still
unreleased music generating model that I
spoke about at the time the people
behind it apparently left because Google
delayed it so long likewise the founders
of character AI left in 2021 when Google
wouldn't launch their chatbot indeed a
lot of the open AI crowd are originally
googlers including satova and it seems
that every month that Google delays the
release of something another group of
their employees leaves to form a startup
it's almost like Pai is a little bit
trapped and Mark Zuckerberg said the
same thing once in his case he said if
he didn't release llama his researchers
would just leave well a lot of Google
deep mine scientists are already leaving
with the kind of valuations that
Bloomberg are talking about the
temptation to just leave these big
companies and form your own startup is
greater than ever so Google are almost
forced to ship something now don't get
me wrong it does seem like an incredibly
powerful model and you don't often get
this message that Gemini isn't available
at the moment try again in a few minutes
but as of now I don't see the evidence
to switch from gp4 to Google Gemini
Ultra of course as someone who analyzes
AI I'm going to be subscribed to both
that doesn't mean I get everything
though unfortunately like most of you
the mobile app for example is only
available in English in the USA and the
image generation capacity is not
available in Europe that's despite me
seeing this image when I first upgraded
to Gemini Advanced so for me it's a
mixed first impression of Gemini Ultra
but I want to hear what you think in the
comments let me know if you think I
missed something obvious or was a bit
too harsh or kind and regardless whether
you're a googler or just your average
guy or gal thank you so much for
watching to the end as always have a
wonderful day